I hope you've all got different
triangles now that's supposedly enough
you just need it don't need to be a
really super accurate measurement here
at my measurements my triangle obviously
substantially larger than yours but what
I want to point out is a very simple
fact about triangles one you've known
for a very very long time but I've never
really had to appeal to you because it's
like well I didn't really had to worry
about have a look at the length of your
triangle okay look at the length of the
sides now can you see it's kind of
plainly obvious that if I take any of
these sides any individual side for
example let's have a look at a V okay
the length of a B cannot possibly exceed
the sums of the lengths of the other two
sides do you see that right you got 61
here this side has to be shorter than or
in a weird case of equal to the sum of
these two sides added together does that
make sense
it's got to be less than or equal to
[ __ ] it can't possibly be more possibly
anymore because if you want to think
about it this way if you have this Saiki
up and it was saying what's the element
to some it's 17 6 yeah right if my um a
B was 80 centimeters right there's no
way that AC and bc with their current
weights could reach out and connect and
make the triangle maybe something like
this
come on you've had you'd have your long
a be there and then BC would try and
reach and ne see try [ __ ] and they just
wouldn't get there right so you can see
61 has to be shorter than these two
added together and I can make the same
argument actually for any of the sides
of the truck right this 41 it's got to
be less than or equal to 4 some of these
two sides and 35 has to be less than or
equal to the suburb these two sides
right otherwise your sides don't connect
you won't get a triangle does that make
sense
okay now this is very very obvious facts
when you're just looking to try it okay
but the reason why I pointed out now is
because the whole point of thinking
geometrically if you remember was that
everything you know about geometry can
then be applied to your complex numbers
okay so I want you to have a think as I
am prymaat my next diagram and you can
draw yourself a complex plane as well
let's student the first quadrant for
this first one triangles pop up
everywhere when you think about complex
numbers and how they relate to each
other okay
in fact you're racing very obvious
relationships who even have a look at
which will take advantage of this so
keeping that guy on the board let's draw
excuse me let's draw ourselves we'll do
it in the first quadrant and complex
plane like so and let's pop a on let's
pop a Zed one is there two on key we
tend to do it something like this
okay now you must obvious first way to
combine this in fact the way we've
always been starting every time we look
at a new idea is let's think about what
happens when we added eight okay let's
figure out what happens when we add them
so if I do said 1 plus said to when I
should said 1 plus said to be on this
diagram what shape will be formed when I
plot Z 1 plus Z 2 it'll be a
parallelogram right because of the
parallelogram law so just give another
color so there's the parallelogram you
can kind of imagine there in the
background and then 1 plus said 2 is
going to take the opposite corner
it's the diagonal in this case it's the
long diagonal of this parallelogram ok
now excuse me because you've got this
parallelogram right a parallelogram is
made of a pair of triangles so I can see
in this diagram thinking about complex
numbers not just this point but as
vectors right for instance type in some
is bottom half with a parallelogram here
right see how I've got into the to think
about that that's the position vector of
zetsu that I've got right there because
it comes from the origin okay there's no
position vector but if I consider one of
the free vectors of z2 one of the free
vectors that represents z2 if I just
move it to the opposite side the
parallel side of the parallelogram
Irving
ok what I've got here is this magnitude
is the same right because that free
vector represents the same complex
aambat okay these legs are gonna be the
same so I'm gonna like that here this is
the position vector so I've still got
that manager there and then that
diagonal it's magnitude is the magnitude
of the Sun okay now have a look at this
triangle here right and what statements
we can make in terms of inequalities
based on this triangle here that is
similar to what we said here
okay so for instance let's come back to
our original triangle I can say that a B
right that's one time a triangle has to
be less than or equal to the sum of the
other two sides right AC plus BC degree
that that's what we've seen before
because if it were great in it and then
the other two sides wouldn't be long
enough to connect and complete the
triangle yeah ah yeah so that's a bit of
a funny case really what would happen if
a B were exactly equal to this sum of AC
NB C that's kind of a good read because
in this context you wouldn't come
triangle anymore would you you'd kind of
just have a straight line and there's
the long side and then you've got one of
the short sides in here and maybe have
the short side there and they just all
sitting on top of each other okay but
strictly speaking the language can still
connect is what I mean right and in the
context of a complex for set of complex
numbers you can still have those and
they can still the intervals of storm a
chart okay so that is a special case
we'll talk about that a bit more in time
but I have to include remembering as
well I can say that statement not just
about one sided triangle I can say it
about any offer all right
so there's one of them I can say it
about AC it's also got to be less than
or equal to the sum of the other two
sides and you be plus BC and I'm
concerned about the last side as well
which is to say okay now based on saying
that you know regular or try you up
there what equivalent statements kind of
made down here in this triangle let me
just um shade this in red so you can see
the
and that's the triangle I'm interested
in
so what statements kind of make based on
the magnitudes of these lengths in this
trial yeah give me one equals okay now
I'm gonna pause for a second so I want
to think about yeah so I want to think
about it in these terms right you
consider one side one side and then
you've gotta say based on the fact that
I want the sides to connect it's gonna
be less than or equal to I can't say it
the other way around and in fact I went
later on for a different triangle but
freaking I'm trying to draw the parallel
between here and here I work on this off
oh that bad okay so there's a um in this
case in my particular diagram that's my
longest side okay and it's less than or
equal to this sum is the other two sides
right is that one there's one of the
sides and is it - there's the other one
the sides you happy with that now I can
just as equally say that football of the
other sides right I can say good morning
I can say that phys ed one I can say it
phys ed - right let's just complete this
set on inequalities
hey no excuse me these are all true
these are all true just like these are
all true okay
however when we talk about inverted
commas the triangle inequalities okay
he said this one here is kind of more
interesting and elegant than the other
two okay this one here refers to the
fact that the modulus of a sum the
magnitude of some vectors is less than
or equal to the sum of the moduli of the
vectors does that make sense right let
me say that again the I'm in fact I'm
gonna write it okay
the modulus of a sum is less than or
equal to this sum of the moduli right
Mondo's so some let's say you go to the
sum of the mods okay we're gonna look at
a on a concrete example of this in a
second but this is all level to
establish for now okay these are both
true as well okay they're just less
interesting to say okay so this is my
first result secondly you remember our
in our parallelogram right that's not
the only triangle that gets created I've
got this try more over here
those that convert met removes convert
to the one I just said so there's no
more interesting stuff there but there
is another triangle based on the other
diagonal what's the other diagonal what
complex number does it represent
inspector okay so I can either think
about in two ways
because remember that vectors have um
have direction right so if I go from
here down to here that's 0 minus m2 or
if I go in the opposite direction
that's it 2-1 okay now I'm only thinking
about links at the moment right so
therefore it doesn't matter which
direction I'm interested in as it
happens the modulus of a son or the one
dose of a difference is the same as if I
turn it around just like an absolute
value right remember
okay we think about this in terms of all
right the absolute value means you
disregard the sum but what it really
means is sorry you disregard this side
but what it really means is you're
thinking about the distance between
these two and no matter which way you're
facing the distance is the same right
does that make sense